[Music]
already Madonna just 12 hours after re
lion Dec junior popped the question to
lauren Burnham on live TV we mani ET sat
down with a newly engaged bachelor
couple in New York City where they
revealed they're already planning their
big day and a big move I'll be moving to
Arizona the last week of this month re
ended his engagement to Becca cofrin
just weeks after filming the finale to
pursue a relationship with Warren the
more I hung out with you the more I felt
like I was losing the possibility of
maybe reconciling things with Warren so
what then on Monday re and Becca's
brutal breakup aired unedited we have
had a lot of conversations about it and
I trust him and I don't think that he
would have taken such a huge risk and
faced all of its backlash if he wasn't
really serious about this decision
during Tuesday's after the final rose re
admitted that he proposed to the
Minnesota native because she was the
safe choice
I feel like he chose the easyread I kind
of knew that was why he made that
decision so I just understand it as for
the haters Ari isn't too concerned I
think part of being genuine is realizing
that here you make mistakes in your
human and not every not every
relationship is going to be perfect not
every bachelor ending is gonna be a
fairy tale but you know we're trying to
block out a lot of that hate and just
concentrate on us and he has no regrets
about how things played out
I think this brought me here with her
and you know this is this is why I came
on the show to meet someone like her and
it's made it all worth it
[Music]